life on the road it's a taco dangling or
strippers waving guns and these flights
canceled flights running with the runs
like this bounce checks great
Bachelorette pumps in the front making
out for yourself and then likes doing
Gollum or missing murchman try the
rental car Paz another mega church to
juice keys vagina pista cell phone his
dog one big law and order
thanks for turning the road stories
podcaster is actually 29 seconds I
thought it was 30 seconds the theme song
but I just looked on that counter it's
29 seconds so was only part of the
themes it wasn't the full theme song if
you want the extended version you got to
go to my album and go for the bonus
track I put it in track number 69
because I'm clever
well it's what do you mention that you
had it last time did you know yeah it's
been a while let's shake it all hold
that thought check in with air and over
at the all things comedy desk what's
going on over there today Tom pop I just
put out a special on epics called human
mule oh right I album will be available
next Friday I haven't watched yet but I
tweeted about it I like Tom Poppy's the
funny dirties yeah it's crazy
everybody is Jerry Seinfeld loves them
that's what I heard okay that's it
that's all things going over there yeah
we all love and no epics we all tuned in
I get my epics are you talking about the
disco record label yeah yeah I don't
know what epics is epics I guess is a
channel like channel yeah I think they
have a deal with Amazon though so you
might be able to find it there as well
okay I don't know there's also
incestuous there's so many things get my
news from epics
hard hard-hitting epics news yeah it's
almost like all these ways to watch
things online is maybe just turning the
television but I don't know maybe I'm
crazy joining me today on the podcast -
very funny guys I'm very excited to have
on I haven't had on in a long time Chris
Fairbanks and Henry Phillips that's me
and him and that's me that's both of you
guys it's funny you're here because I
didn't have the theme song last time
you're here Henry maybe not last time
you were here also but you somebody
asked me where do I came up with all the
lyrics for the pot for the theme song
and it comes from every story so if you
listen to every line it's somebody told
the story on here and you have the last
line in it a one big law-and-order
marathon oh wow yeah cuz that that one
really spoke to me right off the podcast
last time your honor
or you'd mentioned ology dues you
sitting and you just watch Law & Order
there's one you really nailed it that's
really funny it's like listening to a
song and it just coming up putting your
brother's wife's name or something so I
guess you gotta you gotta step it up to
make it into the next version yeah the
pressures on Murray have you been I feel
like I was hanging above you guys in
quite a song yeah in a while it's funny
when someone tells me to step it up I'm
just like I'm I just give up that's me
I'm the other I'm good I'm good good I'm
try to figure out I'm gonna try to
figure out where we met but all three of
us here and I'm gonna break my brain I
haven't thought about this I wrote down
notes because I want to talk to you guys
about something but this is not it Chris
and I met at a theater in Long Beach uh
next to a Walmart I think I have
Alzheimer's so Jack occation book did I
think yeah I remember that and it was a
little black box theater but it is next
tool it was attached to a Walmart how
does this is it just images the
comebacker how many gigs are there in
Long Beach and on Walmart yeah God I
have no recollection uh I mean I you
might have just been I say new to town
but I don't know how long have you been
here
2003 yeah it might have been a couple
years ten years yeah yeah and I were you
had a bust head oh yeah that does go
back now and that was my buzzed head
tough guy yeah yeah timid a lots of
fights you were ahead of it yeah I feel
like it didn't really get big until late
yeah yeah that's something yeah cutting
edge but we don't say crew cut though we
didn't even go full skin I don't wanna I
don't want to set an image that yeah I'm
a it's just you never know how what
stage you got me in right before that I
was all the way all the way bald were
you full skin yeah thin I was hanging
out with these
they were kind of racist and the music
was terrible really but yeah it's like
the dancing was just punching get these
rallies blaring you wear a bunch of sand
wear red suspenders no shoelaces oh yeah
we were the non racist first I love the
different types of skinheads fur they're
like oh no no we're not racist skinheads
we look at my shoelaces yeah yeah
moderately racist yeah it's kind of like
our not big fans of rap music there is
yeah there is like there is group of a
group called sharp switch skinheads
against racial president sure I did you
you're fighting it by looking like them
that's good we're hanging out with a
bunch of non racist skinheads and they
get really pissed that's what I'm
winning by a bunch I mean three so yeah
that's what I'm trying to do with square
middle-aged white guys get them from
within yeah
so we met you and I met I don't recant
recall where we met I feel like it was
in front of Stratton's in Westwood oh I
don't know what's the Hardwick remember
we used to hang out down there remember
you're at Westwood Boulevard Murray step
it up
no I'm recruiting in my shell straddles
with Stratton's Madison's Chris Hardwick
used to hang out there a bar time yeah
Madison bar oh I'm sorry it was called
Stratton's before though it was okay all
right back one yeah yeah Chris was a
skinhead yeah yeah then they changed the
name of it but yeah I feel like it was
there yeah okay Chris used to hang out
there all the time and then I was
hanging out and you were there too and
they I just went up chatting the whole
night and then yeah and then since then
I've hung out at the improv and sure in
the comedy you weren't there the night I
almost got into a fistfight were you I
don't think so
this is horrible all right so oh yeah
yeah that's right you started getting in
a fistfight and I started running away
yes I remember now by the way I remember
if you ever want to get anybody to back
you up you don't have comics I saw the
marching band back in
I'll go get help because what happens
alright the waitress gave my credit card
to the wrong person by the way it's one
minute to two where they got to clear
everybody out at 2:00 a.m. and she gave
my credit card to somebody else and
there and she's like oh my god I'm so
sorry
here go to the phone and call your
credit card and tell him to stop it so I
go the phone and call my credit card
company and some guy who was working
there wasn't working there that night
was drunk and they're trying to clear
everybody out and clear everybody out
and he goes hey [ __ ] you got to get
out of here and hangs up the phone on me
well like right when I get to my credit
card and so I snapped so I put some
drunk oh yeah I snap and the guy you
have to call you an ass oh yeah and hang
up the phone out of here [ __ ] so him
and his buddies just come at me and I go
at them and I look behind me and this is
how I remember Riley Newton I don't know
if you remember her oh yeah yeah a very
nice lady blaine capatch
weighs 85 pounds soaking wet Zach
Galifianakis is passed out face down and
Hardwick is just hammered somewhere I
got five frat guys coming at me and
everybody behind me Wow that was the
last time I almost got a fight Wow
something they didn't end up punching
now they held it like they held it back
like it was lit like I had I'm fists
clenched and and back about a self
defense man yeah yeah Wow it's a shame
we don't hang out there anymore
yeah though I actually yeah well you
know I went to college at UCLA and that
was always the place to go as a matter
of fact I used to go there before I was
even at UCLA and just to hang out on
campus yeah but yeah it was crazy
there'd be girls in the men's bathroom
what this is like North Carolina yeah
yeah that's not like that was the thing
that happened all the time I just
suddenly a memory yeah I was very like
they were just hanging out like smoking
even I think he could smoke back back in
those days maybe in the men's bathroom
it was more comfortable to smoke the
men's bathroom yeah I didn't want to
mess up the the women's bathroom and
smoke historically speaking men's
bathrooms are very comfortable yeah
being offended I complained to the
manager
there isn't a hit song called smokin in
the girls room haha
I there's a hit there's always one
Bananarama has a song called why don't
they have ashtrays in there yeah this is
so Hardwick was like best friend to
school together went to UCLA together
the guy who ran this bar so and so there
was that what was the place across this
yeah it was always after the the brew Co
the brew Co brew Co ur that Julie always
go up there yeah nobody goes there we
get hammered number one this is the type
of clientele you get that this bar I
remember one Halloween Hardwick and I
were there and everybody was dressed up
and one guy walked you know one guy high
school you know just high school college
just buff no shirt in a towel and like
foam on his head you know like he just
got out of the shower you know and then
on his on his back he had posted a
post-it note that had an arrow on his
but that said exit only just that real
type of jock coma but we drank for free
so we went there also probably trying to
use reverse psychology yeah yeah why
talk about it if you don't want it real
bad yeah yeah yeah don't do me in the
but nobody do that don't put this ball
gag that I already have on me in my
mouth yeah unacceptable
I do remember seeing you in uh in
Stanhope at Luna Park oh yeah yeah yours
and you already when I first started
IARC was that was like a haven that
place was fantastic place was great it
was a little a little bit restaurant bar
7 96 98 something like that well have
any closer to 98 I think yeah there was
some really fun ones there yeah and
Stanhope I remember specifically this
Aspen Comedy Showcase and it was the
dumbest thing because they they were
auditioning people for Aspen and Doug
Stanhope they thought it would be a
great idea to have him as the emcee but
he wasn't eligible to be in the they
just had already rejected him to be in
the fest right right he's too dirty or
sure but they were like can you host
just a crazy idea his entire set was it
was so over-the-top hardcore that making
everybody wanted you know all the
industry people squirm and he was also
insulting the comics after they were oh
that's always a great thing to do do
crowd rap in front of a bunch of
Industry people you idiot it's like what
do you do sir I sit in the dark and
judge you now go on with your stupid dog
and pony show so we can get on like I
remember just like it was just so great
but and then afterward there was a lot
of partying yeah Luna Park was know as a
haven we around for that you probably
miss no I don't think so yeah it's in
Austin it was uh I used to open for a
show called the but Pirates of the
Caribbean everyone the improv sketch
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was it
was a musical yeah and that was in the
big room and that was crazy yeah there
was like celebrities that would come in
and everything and uh and then there was
the downstairs room where they had
comedy and yeah I remember on cabaret it
was all right right yeah that place was
I mean low ceilings
yeah bar it was really cool I I don't
know if you get smoke in there and I
don't remember probably I mean that's
something we forget is that until about
98 or something it was no bar that you
couldn't smoke yeah yeah there would
never be they never even thought about
it they never said now we're gonna ban
smoking like you know are you still
smoking uh you know every now and then
I'll have a little bit of a cigarette
okay yeah
for God work with Henry on the road we
both smoked and it's so funny it wasn't
that long ago but I haven't just smoking
and they're like waking up and smoking
yeah we did that Tulsa gig right oh my
god
yeah we have some Stanley was on stage
and the the guy that runs the club who's
died right he is but he was the worst
yeah it was the worst it's one most
feels so terrible after someone dies for
you to have nothing like uh he was a
good guy but I can't make myself say oh
yeah I think his wife always had like a
black
yeah and they lived they put you in a
condo and he lived across the street and
his kids would come over memory as kids
but would like no pants on run around
and Henry was on stage and he had gotten
all tuned up at the Larry the Cable
guy's show what she went to instead of
the show at his own the owner and Henry
is on stage and he just got on stage and
pulled his pants down and moon the
audience yeah and what did you say yeah
and I was like well normally they kick
that guy out but that's the owner Elsa I
got punched in the face after show
they're slow in slow motion what are
having a no war in Iraq poster on my
back window it was my girlfriend's car
and I borrowed it and I didn't realize
she put a giant banner in the back it
was behind the driver's window see what
are you doing and people were honking
and flipping me off the closer I got to
Tulsa because it was a time where you
were really supportive don't you wish
you were back the same where at time say
now both candidates both agree that it
was a stupid idea right yeah it's like
even your you know hardcore you know
right-wing you know it's like it was a
stupid idea it's like well why don't you
tell all those [ __ ] yeah after the
show was just he was even saying I
thought you were great and then saw that
and he got in my face and I said you're
the type of person that is angry right
now that's just the difference between
you annoy any now he like pushed punched
he was old so I if you ever had an old
man hit you just my dad so strange yeah
if it was my dad I'd be like well you
just love me and don't know how to show
it but strangers and he pushed he just
made a fist and pushed my chin with it
so it wasn't really he wanted to hit me
so he's just showing me where he would
have done it and then applying more
pressure if I will you ever got swung at
anybody terrible or I told him well I
mean not since high school well
yeah but now not not as an adult no no
sage now didn't you oh no I think people
have probably thrown things yeah did
your chairs thrown at you one time oh
yeah yeah I I had a football thrown at
me at one of these college gigs pretty
hilarious it literally I was in the
middle of my song and it just bounced
off my head I just did I just ignored it
I just kept on going
balanced off the top of my head yeah can
you tell I'm a musician I have no
athletic skills
don't throw well and also you're playing
guitar and doing an act supposedly what
are you still doing colleges um no no no
I haven't done those and yours we're
about to you're you still doing colleges
I don't even wanna go on the road
anymore no don't know once that map lit
up all red during the election I was
like I'm not gonna go these cones
anymore really it's just sad not to know
more yeah [ __ ] those people all right
[ __ ] most everyone so wide go I don't
want to go and try and make those people
laugh there's a lot of cool places you
know plenty of things you can do with
comedy other didn't go to some [ __ ]
for $900 so yeah but so much places are
starting to you know they're all
terrible Henry no I like I like
Louisville Kentucky lon
oh you always liked that place yeah I've
always that you've always liked
Louisville uh hanging out at Madison's
you're like one day I'm going to
Louisville no it actually I I never
really worked there until a couple years
ago yeah uh yeah it's great it's totally
you know it's not the character like no
it's called the Laughing Derby oh and oh
okay yeah no and it's great um they've
got they you know have like a cool
little a lot of these places have like
their own kind of Haight Ashbury look
you know like the final record stores
and smoke shops and stuff like that and
it's you know pretty progressive in the
urban areas you know it's not like
you're going to
the Appalachian all right well I don't
know Kentucky yeah but um yeah I like a
lot of these places but huh
here's Michael here's my I took notes
they aren't asking me law and order
scratch it oh yeah uh do burnt you open
for bands much did you I've done it
before I haven't done that in quite a
while
yeah how do they respond to oh man there
was one there was one situation where I
was in Myrtle Beach and I was open up
for a band called three doors down
oh yeah and what was their hit uh hold
on Aaron has tasted shitty music
kryptonite oh no well there was I'm sure
he's a good that was just all these
people that was like I think it was it
yeah it was it some rock band you know I
want to say House of Blues but I don't
think it was that but it was that kind
of thing and it was just I was up there
trying to do my stand-up and my guitar
and everything and they're like the
first all I could see really were the
first ten rows and I just remember
people's faces just so angry just like
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know just going like
that and but I did it you know cuz it
was a good paycheck
sure yeah when I was done I walked
offstage and the people from the radio
that were promoting over like that was
awesome that was great I was like what
what about the fact that everybody was
yelling [ __ ] you and they're like no no
they do that for everybody and I'm like
all right well maybe everybody sucks you
can't like just assume it's good but uh
yeah and then I thought it was pretty
funny because afterward there was this
entire group of girls that look like
hooters type girls and they were all
just lined up to go to go back to the
bus with the band and the band came out
and just sort of picked which ones that
they wanted really grabbed him yeah now
those guys can't even get Hooters girls
you know from adda hooters they get
kicked out I love that three doors down
has very bad little hands yeah yeah well
no I mean I think it's more
these towns you know like when they go
to a rock concert they get so pumped up
mm-hmm and the kind of dry comedic
stylings of that's not really what
they're looking for yeah I've never had
it work to open program no didn't
terrible I who was it who was it you
open for the first opening Oh
Cyndi Lauper yeah I told that story but
we are in that no no I just no I I ate
it and I was told to get off stage and I
was terrible things were yelled at me at
Cyndi Lauper people it's not the right
yeah yeah yeah they got a grow as if
they were a death metal chill because
you could be at a Neil Sedaka
and then afterwards yeah were they
throwing stuff at you I just was hungry
and I did bad some things were thrown I
didn't really stop to look at what they
were but I think just like pieces of
popcorn bags or whatever
Vanetta whatever the concert and then
after where it's like a it's like I they
fired me right when I got offstage and I
was like yeah that's what I would have
done and then I was like I was promised
a meal
and then they just stared at me and took
me down this hallway and there was that
what was left over of like a buffet
situation but it was all picked over old
it was like hours old and there was just
lettuce I remember lettuce and some ball
like cheese balls and some dressing and
I just made a cheese ball salad and they
all were just staring at me these
Brodie's waiting for me to eat I could I
had to stay in town and go back to get
my check they didn't want to pay me but
I got down to the fifth or sixth cheese
ball on this salad when I realized I was
eating butter a little butter balls
rolls that weren't there anymore
I ate five or six though yeah man so
wait they wouldn't pay you and I was it
was a point in my life where it's like
kind of healthy and I threw them I threw
them on all this in front of those
people really feel like I'm not gonna
keep those in my body and you guys fired
me so I'm gonna throw up in this
trashcan now oh jeez yeah it's the way
if it's what a great gig that was
supposed to be a string of dates
opening for cyndi lauper that was like
right gonna take care of things I just
picture all this happening while she's
singing true colors in the background
well yeah didn't you tell yeah I think
you also mentioned that like the the
show itself didn't go well right and
then I think Cindy Lauper heard about it
and at one point she's walking past the
green room and looks in there and just
sees you throwing up with a trash can
and didn't you hear her say like oh is
that the guy like as if that's the
reason you're throwing up just had a
terrible stage fright about it she ever
looked at me while I stand or no in the
greenroom afterward or bags I there it's
funny when someone Oh didn't this also
happen and then you realize at one point
maybe you lied to your friend okay cuz I
remember
oh no I'm definitely amazing happen I'd
rather think that it happened and you
forgot yes I think he told me right
after I want to pay like one of my
listeners to go back and listen to my
first putt and listen to them all the
way through because I've repeated you
know oh yeah yeah every week I've I want
to see how it's escalated throughout the
nine years that one story is well you
got to make it entertaining so all of a
sudden there's this punchline in there
that was something you made up it's like
because stories in general or you'll
combine stories like example there's a
great way it happens like I did a I did
a show in Nashville and backstage they
were we were sharing the theater with a
group in the big theater that was doing
wicked but we were sharing the backstage
so every time I went backstage there
would be these flying monkey guys he's
just running around frantically you know
but so that would be a good way to
combine that like like Chris you can
have that like you can be like oh yeah
and then also the theater was attached
to this wicked thing where they had
flying monkeys and now you've got flying
monkeys yeah yeah Cyndi Lauper story and
you're not really lying you're just
taking too much yeah because why
wouldn't you want flying monkeys in this
story and attach that theater to a
Walmart yeah yeah and it all comes
around where Law & Order is playing yeah
owners showing his ass it's like
everything the one night everything
happens the one bad night is stand up
yeah now how is it well you and uh April
just spend a lot of time together didn't
you
April Richardson yeah just we had hosted
a show together and then it got canceled
but then you go out on the road now we I
guess we did some shows yeah it wasn't
really it am i upsetting you I I really
am like I don't want to do the routing
you can stay good at Skanda and make
money other ways then I'm tired of
flying somewhere it's very disrespected
so I'm over it yeah I'm deciding that
right now all right right yeah we did
shows together they were fine it was we
went to a few cities but I've never gone
on like a tour where you do like 10
cities in a row totally guys did
everyone calls them tours but yeah if
someone's doing did you do go there a
famous person or they're doing shitty
gigs we do not actually make it money
right and they're just listing them all
so they can tell people they went on the
road or they could be the opening act I
toured with Stanhope but I certainly
wouldn't say that I was right in touring
yeah I opened for Daniel Tosh a few
times but I wouldn't say I went on tour
yeah it's kind of one of those things
that like friends of yours that aren't
in the business like friends from high
school so are you on tour now yeah yeah
yeah okay let's call it being on tour
I'm at you know bar well but you can't
like I just did a tour no no I know what
you mean yeah yeah you can't I I guess
that it's well for me it's always been
just if a club calls me then I show up
right right well yeah there's I don't
really have like a like a t-shirt that's
got you know February 17 you know 18 I
mean I guess you could but I don't know
how you'd make enough money you know
yeah maybe yeah I don't know how it gets
done if other people are doing it maybe
I'm not as popular as I thought who
knows maybe did you do go bananas when
you were there did you go in an SRE I
don't yeah I didn't did
a nanny in a long time I think you went
to Bloomington that's supposed to be
like that's like the big it's at the
Attic yeah yeah I just when have you
done that I got on the other paid
nothing got my check left pissed off had
great shows it just doesn't make sense
about the best year money-wise of my
life and it's by staying in town I think
I talked to you right after the Attic oh
yes I remember you saying that exact
same thing yeah shows were great and got
paid nothing and um yeah yeah yeah
there's clubs don't want to pay any more
well I think that like the costs of
doing it have gone way up to like the
yeah flight cost
absolutely which I don't get because
they'll be like you know oh it's because
of fuel or whatever or it's because
people aren't they're afraid of fly but
it's like well fuel costs go down and
then all of a sudden you're on a flight
and every single person is on their pack
like sardines so it's like well why is
it going up still but yeah it makes it
so that it's really difficult to pull
off no I just
I believe it or not I got asked to do
few dates I don't know if it's a tour or
not in Canada and they're like oh this
is what this is what we're paying
Canadian and then I did the math in the
exchange know it's like 72 cents on the
dollar or something yeah yeah there and
I'm like there's no possible way I can
get up to Canada and and do this I
pulled out of my last Canada Games I'm
like I'm not doing this sorry and they
were mad and I probably won't ever be a
speck yeah well that's the other thing
that pisses me off about pulling out I
got a Booker I got I was kinda I was
doing New York in New Jersey and going
through Pennsylvania and in New York and
New Jersey canceled and so I had to pull
out of Pennsylvania plenty of time and I
think I was doing I was middling as a
favor for my friend and the guy got
really pissed off it's like you'll never
work here again like we can't find a
middle act for your club yeah three
weeks
you're pretty hurt it's like what do you
want me to go eat you know a grand and
airfare and make whatever it was five
hundred by the middle for a buddy as a
favor that's crazy you know yeah I'm not
doing it Fairbanks is rubbing off on me
[ __ ] I'm done I saw another TV show
forget it
I quit yeah that's what well I think
that if yeah
if there were a way yeah because I I
started that this year I started doing a
lot of other things in town and I was
like am I making more money by not being
not working because of all the plane
costs and everybody why do I feel like I
have more expendable cash right now I'm
not working yeah but ya know if you can
well the ID the goal is to eventually
show up and have at least half of the
audience be there specifically to see
you
right and then then all the shows are
great and the only works out way you can
get that to happen is by being known
from a thing that you have to stand
exactly yeah known from right yeah now
there's so many fantastic you don't
guess but do you know how much work it
would take and how often you'd have to
go and have them bring you to a club for
you to build an audience from doing
stand-up there that's not oh no
I you know I saw this guy last time I
remember his name let's go to his
website there's a link no one's ever
done there is behind like oh yeah it
just doesn't work it's a flawed system
and I'm I'm tired of it and I know this
is a podcast that's celebrating it yeah
well in that case we should talk about
remember when we did oh I have the
Roadster we gotta talk to him but you
gotta tell about Little Rock Little Rock
remember that one we did a whole week at
this it was sort of an improv slash
funny bone in Little Rock Arkansas
the minute I showed up I just had a
roommate I'd the roommate was like the
house MC that month and I walked in the
condo and his wet socks and underwear
oh is this Sam it was like a moat on the
floor that he had created and he was
just playing video games he had dealt
with the issue as far as he was
concerned but the toilet had overflowed
and he used his dirty socks and
underwear as a moat to just keep it out
of the living room and out of the entry
cuz he knew I showing up so he's doing
me a favor I'm not having the toilet
water that was Sam right and then I had
my own room there was it was big
heavy-duty partying unless I'm mixing
two different
it was it was a lot of hardcore partying
and it was a lot of fun I remember the
next morning that guy was taking us to
the radio and it was like 6:30 in the
morning it is awful
hungover and everything and we make it
through the radio and all I want to do
is get back maybe have like a subway
breakfast sandwich and then go back to
bed and this drive home is taking like
an hour longer than the way there and
I'm like what's going on or oh I thought
I'd show you the Dillard's headquarters
I'm like are you out of your [ __ ]
mind like why would I want to see the
Dillard's head cord well it's a big
thing here in Little Rock or whatever
it's like no just take me back to this
wasn't really a Dillard tech yeah it was
the Dillard's headquarters what's at
that weird bizarro Paul Simon guy yeah
Wow what's a Paul Simon guy just it's a
guy that like Paul's look like all
something right yeah yeah the club in
Houston now it was a huge train wreck
yeah I mean they went out of business I
think a month later mm-hmm and they had
just gone into business a month before
we got there they were like dealing
credit cards well they were giving out
all all the booze to all their friends
like somebody was like hey there's a
comedy club let's just everybody owns a
comedy club let's go drink for free type
thing yeah yeah but Henry was in a panic
for one of the shows because he had lost
his guitar got stole a sandwich shop
next door oh no really let our guitar in
there and and so he borrowed one from a
local the next day opens his trunk and
he had just put it in his truck like
back out yeah it turns out the guy was a
good Samaritan yeah he returned it right
I think I lied about it I was like oh
yeah the guy the sandwich shop said
somebody dropped off a guitar I had
already come to terms with losing now I
recall you putting it back I was with
you I all
forgot no I think what happened is the
guy put it in my trunk yeah yeah wanted
to key made to where it was rental car
just that's like carrot top strongman
yeah but yeah I remember and there was
that one show that I always remember
just terrible terrible like I guess late
Saturday night show or whatever and I'm
just bombing I'm up there for like 40
minutes I can't get any laughs at all
and it was kind of time for me to get
off anyway the people are just staring
there was just no connection right and
there was a lady III made some joke like
well I'm gonna make this the last song
or something like that and then oh you
made her lady yeah this lady in the
audience yells good and I just pissed me
off so much yeah so I tried to be all
polite I was like wait I'm sorry I
missed what you said man what was that
and then she's like kind of like
reluctant to have the spotlight on her
sure I said good oh good meaning oh you
don't want to hear any more
okay so you didn't you don't like it I
guess she's like yeah okay you know what
um hey everybody I she doesn't like it
it doesn't seem like any you guys like
it I'm not having a good time if you're
not having a good time maybe this just
wasn't meant to be and I don't know
maybe we should just call it a night
I'll see you later everybody felt sorry
for me and then they hated that lady and
I went out in the front to sell my CDs
and I'll never forget like I had I had
not sold any CDs the entire make some
big cowboy guy comes up to me and he's
like hey man you know what I don't
really like the way that lady treated
you and I want to let you know that's
not the way we are in this town as a
matter of fact you know what why don't
you give me one of those CDs I think I'd
like that I'm gonna take one of those
CDs you know give me two I'm gonna give
one to my brother I think he'll enjoy
that don't don't listen to what that
lady said and then the lady's like
walking out and shame and everybody's
just going what an awful one I'm selling
a whole bunch of CDs because people felt
sorry I remember
or that I had that's exactly yeah and I
wanted to be like well maybe I should do
that have people feel sorry for me every
time
do you have a song that's a go-to when
it's not going well um yeah well I mean
I have a lot more standup nowadays so I
don't have one liners so that you can
always sort of do that but not to sound
like a dick but it hasn't not gone well
for a while so I don't remember what I
used to talk to Fairbanks no I know I
think those early years you're always
trying to figure out what kind of
material to do for which audiences and
whatever and that's what I was
struggling with because I was coming
from LA where everybody just was
anticipating jokes yeah whereas in a
comedy club with just regular people you
just had to sort of spell it out a
little bit more and it took me a while
to iron that out I used to start with
like two minutes of no jokes whatsoever
just a complete troll trying to get
people to think that it was a real
singer-songwriter and then I were sort
of slowly turned into like oh this is a
gag and that was tough you have to do on
the road that was really difficult so
started just nowadays I open with like
maybe 15 minutes of stand-up and I just
pick up the guitar and do a few songs
but yeah if there's ever a law I'll I'll
try to you know I have a couple
one-liners at my stage that I can pull
out or there's my end of the world song
is usually mm-hmm
a party getter now do you think it's the
party do you stand up are you sitting
down on the stool um you know what I'd
change it up exciting hours take notes
yeah and then I'll take a stool and I'll
sit on it for a couple of songs and then
I'll get up and so it's a different show
every time just a different town well
what are you keeping busy then doing
since you don't want to go out on the
road I am on the relevant just don't
it's the city's I do go and it goes well
when I do it was it is Paris if he's
tired of doing it though okay just like
no okay so I'm in Act
commercial all right that was I asked
what are you doing besides going on the
road
oh man I love getting and uh yeah I'm
hosting a TV show and that got canceled
and then yeah I'm good acting work and
pay bills with that
all right good god we just did a video
together yeah what was a video
it's a Henry's kitchen and of course
Henry's kitchen is great holiday fish
still and it's gonna come out I guess
tomorrow oh that's awesome if yeah I'll
put on I'll put a couple of clips on the
wedding it's gonna be really funny yeah
that's great um I've been having these
air B&B guests and Chris and Melissa
McQueen do you know Melissa McQueen
she's compression aesthetics
I just want to paint a with a big Brush
but it does it very well she I just like
I became friends with her on Facebook is
she new to town has she been around
forever okay I remember when I first
moved here we both were managed by Dave
Rath and we went to the Christmas party
oh okay and Dave had a way of like he
had like hundreds of clients even though
he said I have like 12 and we went to
the Christmas party and he went up and
introduced himself to her what and she's
like no I know you're my manager oh oh
so what tell us a little bit about the
second punching the clown coming in
which yeah yeah no Chris is in it too
and does him yeah we've got give us a
little backstory man a little backstory
a bunch well it's uh there are a lot
more Road stories in this one there's a
whole third act where I basically takes
place on a little Northern California
and Nevada mini tour you know and yeah
like Carson City and and it's based that
whole section is based on one weekend
that I had up there uh-huh
you know where there was just so many
things going wrong and well yeah that
there was a little bit of a demand for
making a sequel to the movie because
even though the first one wasn't a
financial success a lot of people saw it
and a lot of errand chicken said he saw
he loved that
thanks and yeah people like in high
places like my judge you know it was a
fan of it okay he would show it all of
his friends and everything and then when
the time came to make the movie
obviously you have to have a celebrity
that's just unfortunately that's the way
it works because otherwise people don't
go if they don't know who any of the
people in it are so somebody sent out an
email to JK Simmons and a whole bunch of
other people and you know it was
generally like you know like Danny
DeVito it's like hey do you want to do
this independent film and it would be
like his agent saying not sure if you
know but Danny DeVito is [ __ ] famous
like stop insulting us with this [ __ ]
but JK Simmons believe it or not was the
one guy who his agent said you know what
he's kind of interested oh cool
and it's right before I got a Golden
Globe and an Oscar yeah but he had
already done that the movie whiplash it
was actually out at the time and and so
I sent an email to my judge and was like
I hate doing this I'm not very good at
asking people you know for favors like
that but I knew that he was a fan of the
movie and I knew that they were an extra
he made extract and so that they were
probably friends right right and yeah my
judge wrote a fantastic email to JK
Simmons just saying you got to see the
first movie read the script for the
second one you'll have a good time and
that was it that oh that's awesome
so JK Simmons came on board and and also
Sarah Silverman was always a huge fan of
the first one sure she plays this
podcaster that goes throughout she's
great taking a taro actually I think we
showed we all watched the movie with
Diggs the first time back in like 2008
or 2009 or something when they were
roommates uh-huh and I was looking at
Chris when I said that but uh yeah so he
just all these people kind of came can't
stepped up but also like yeah let's do
it you know and so there's probably
about fifty
characters in there and at least 30 of
hundred comics you know mansion and all
Chaplin and I don't want to start naming
them because there are so many out no no
that's fine Jim Jeffries Doug that's
great and now there premiered itself
myself less yeah yeah
how is that I know uh it's weird cuz
that's sort of my comedy home tonight in
Austin and it's hard yeah I've done it
twice okay and it's been very fun good
night I got to go again but it's hard to
get in is it was basically just such a
[ __ ] that I don't know if I'm
just too old for that kind of right
whatever but I all I wanted to do the
whole time was just go to some mellow
div' bar outside of the area and just
hang out with friends and tell stories
and stuff it was just a madhouse but you
know and it's hard I think with your
movie there to get any kind of press or
any word of mouth or get people to show
up to the screenings because there's
just so much going on and people just
will do what they do and I I felt like
it was different the first movie more of
a what would you say big fish in a
little pond kind of a situation where as
I felt like at South by Southwest we got
lost and one of one of the things that
we found out is that the name didn't
work what we called it and punching the
clown think it would be funny because
there's a whole subplot in the movie
where they're trying to come up with a
TV show and they find out about
something called alpha stacking where if
you call your movie something else
aardvark
yeah right and you get listed first in
like the VOD listings like if you're on
the plane it says like a dysentery the
producers all yeah really did want and
they really thought that was a good idea
and so and punching the clown was this
kind of like double funny like inside
thing and then there was a moment there
where I'd like like I told my uber
driver about it and he couldn't stop
laughing about it and all this stuff and
I thought it'd be a funny panel story
like well we wanted to call it
but anyway it was just too confusing and
the worst part is a lot of people kept
on thinking oh I already saw that movie
oh yeah Cory thought it was the one that
they saw several years ago because my
word and it's just not enough especially
like you can't call something like you
know I don't know an Schindler's List
I expect people to think it's not the
same movie it's so like that's I heard I
heard a comic I guess or a manager on an
interview one time talking about naming
the tracks on your album yeah and I feel
bad cuz a friend of mine did this but he
didn't do it for this reason he did it
for a completely different and it's name
you named your tracks popular songs oh
yeah I won't mention his name good a
good friend of ours did that but he
didn't do it for that reason he did it
because he does a joke yeah he did it
for another reason so I don't want to
bang on oh no of course of course it is
it's like that marketing kind of no yes
that would have been exactly a funny
thing to put right our movie you know
what I inadvertently did it oh wow oh
yeah because when I recorded my I went
off on a rant on blink-182 and it got a
really good response so I just left it
on my CD yeah and I named it blink 182
yeah and it's my most downloaded oh yeah
right not funny
no of course and do people are like oh I
like and then they hear me [ __ ] on
blank when I'm inadvertently the
douchebag yeah no well that was thanks
with the and punch in the clown we
actually were the beneficiaries of it
because sure enough like in in a
newspaper article that was like things
to watch in South by Southwest and
there's like 15 movies ours was first oh
right on and so it's sort of like oh I
get it it really does work but it also
is
a pretty cheesy move because you're kind
of admitting that your movie isn't good
enough that people are gonna like it
anyway I have to like do little tricks
right and I did I'm glad you changed it
I just let sound and punching the clown
it's almost like you want to go what it
what is it cost a collection of words
that don't yeah I why would ya or
another made Morten wasn't that well the
whole nother punching the whole point of
it was that it was supposed to sound
stupid if you see the movie okay totally
makes sense because it's supposed to be
so dumb that the only good thing about
it is is starting with it right right
but it's too hard to name your actual
movie that because people will just not
go and you cover all the aids and yeah
because you can't go AB a because
numbers like alright come even earlier
really the way to go is like zero zero
zero zero zero 0.1 or my um it's called
ten monkeys yeah yeah exactly
well when does it come out you just got
24 yeah awesome theaters in theaters
every really yes a little bit exciting
yeah and what about those platforms
uh yeah it'll it'll be a first time in
my life somebody the same thing you know
VOD yeah so it'll be yeah Xbox and
iTunes awesome Zahn and all that stuff
hung February 24th Netflix I I hope it
venture ends up on Netflix cuz that's
great exposure I don't know I think it's
a big mystery how to get stuff on
Netflix Netflix is going through a big
weird change right now and Amazon is
stepping up I know a couple people who
had a deal with Netflix or how to deal
with Amazon but and were promised
Netflix but now they're competing so
they've lost their specials on Netflix
and stuff I love Amazon I think it's
great as an independent guy you can put
your stuff on Amazon through CreateSpace
so our movie punched the clown the first
one it's only on Amazon no real way to
see it Oh perfect you have till February
24th to
watch ya the clown on Amazon that's
awesome and then this is five years
later which I got to say though we
designed it so that you wouldn't have to
see the first move sure to know anything
about it yeah let's see the first movie
anyway
yeah why I'm chiming in cuz he's my
friend I know some of this stuff not let
I'd I have nothing to do with the movie
other than being in it for a second
well that's good yeah I keep I'm like
yeah yeah that's what we did when we got
JK Simmons
I mean alright yeah Chris the scenes
great he plays a little truck driver I
don't think it's any coincidence not
it's we're both from Missoula Montana
that's are you from no I'm not all right
no no JK Simmons yeah Jake Hayes from
spoke at my college when I graduated my
why is this actor who isn't that
well-known yet speaking at the college
well alright
we have listeners from Mizzou when you
get famous I will say everybody claims
you I'm waiting for it to happen it's
gonna be like Englewood New Jersey like
yeah this is his hometown well I was
there for three years that's what my
town in New Jersey did from yannick oh
yeah
Derek Jeter was born there and then
moved out at like six months yeah god
dammit they'll tell you every every
conversation you have with them yeah
Australia try to claim Mel Gibson
they're like for five years I always
assumed he was a stray yeah let me tell
you I never knew that oh wow ya know why
Lauren's New York well that's funny yeah
when I was 12
it's so many surprises with that yellow
that's one of the least controversial
ones alright guys so we got punch of the
crowd Chris what's coming up with you
I'm going on Instagram you're I love the
pictures you put up oh I just joined
Instagram that's what yeah oh yeah I've
been doing these up well that's there's
like these accidental videos that I've
been doing where I'm just trying to you
get navigated or go to WebMD and figure
out why I have a rash but the cameras
accidentally on so it's all these
accidental Jeff video recording it's
kind of have to see it on Instagram yeah
but it's funny it's like who am i
reaching with that other than the people
already following me on instagram but
maybe
were to hit the streets that's the way
it always is and then we have your fan
base and you're hoping that they tell
people I'm going to Denver that's a
place I like to go many works
that's place I like to go no I don't
clubs no thanks I'll just go what's
immoral at a place and figure that you
can make more money yeah no I've been
gone a lot lately
there's no reason to do them like this
goes out to all you comedy clubs working
around you and you're gonna go out of
business huh and uh I'd like time I was
in Denver I ran into this girl that I I
didn't seem for like 12 years and I
remembered 12 years prior we were I was
with a group of friends like two friends
and they had girlfriends I'm about to
tell stories that all right please to
wrap it up no go ahead and would they
she was really rich she lived in Denver
and she lived on they lived on like a
polo court like there was actual horses
and people play Pope in the middle of
the city mm-hmm I've since not found
this place but we rise there 12 years
ago and uh and she she hadn't they had
like Butler's and her parents didn't
talk to her and stuff in a big fancy
house and we were uncomfortable and so
she said well we have a cabin but it was
winter and she was like we there's no
plumbing up there though we had to turn
off the water because the pipes little
trees and explode so we can go up there
but you have to go the bathroom now and
I'm like I don't have to go to the
bathroom now let's have a grown-up don't
tell me when the pooping guy and then we
all got in this car and we drove up up
this mountain and it it was this cabin
was a house it was a beautiful that they
called a cabin they're like oh we can
rough it up at the cabin but a
four-story beautiful house but it was it
was there were snowdrifts like blowing
over it no one had been there for a long
time the plumbing was off and I did have
to [ __ ] right when I got there like I
had to go to the bathroom and they were
just playing board games and I was
pacing around I was I think I had
colitis at the time or something like
that and she so I was like you know what
I'm just gonna go I didn't want to tell
them right so I went outside and I shat
in the snowdrift and I came in and they
all had gone off to I think to make
outers
but I scam like are you guys done like I
walked around the cabin let's see if
anyone was still awake and then in the
morning she was screaming because
someone had tracked human [ __ ]
throughout the entire cabin it was me
there's like and it wasn't like it was
just I got a little bit on my boot right
it was like full I don't know how it was
like I took a paint roller and covered
these boots and just there's just a
perforated line through the whole cabin
like me trying to go to every room I
can't believe how much I and but they
didn't somehow it wasn't known that it
was narubu that was me
yeah and that was my human [ __ ] I
cleaned I'm like that's guilty right
away I'm like oh I'll clean it after
that they had all this resolved so I
cleaned the carpet and they I didn't
care about it for the rest of that trip
I remember I was like well I dodged that
bullet but I couldn't remember what how
I got out of it and but then when I saw
her this last time she was like Oh
remember up at the cabin when you
stepped in wolf [ __ ] like I guess I then
I'd stepped in wolf's head so and smell
that's for yeah I totally cried wolf
[ __ ] no Chris will be in Denver win that
I don't know it doesn't I'm in your
website it's yeah don't know my website
why do you still talk to that many
analysts mid January January 50 perfect
yeah it's freezing places when they're
negative 9 absolutely frozen that's when
I like - I do like winter no last time I
went to Montana
you know my parents live in Bozeman now
oh yeah yeah and it was negative 30
yeah it's I'm about to go yeah it's
crazy
it's insane I'm okay with that so check
out Chris Fairbanks on Instagram check
out Chris Fairbanks calm write Twitter
the whole nine yards right yeah I mean
your SubPop hat all my name all my name
no spaces no underscores there are
periods and Henry Phillips we got punch
in the club yeah wait punch in Henry
Phillips punching Henry punch in Henry
okay
yeah that's February and then also
probably by the time that this comes out
you can see the video that Chris and I
just made the Henry's kitchen holiday
fish do awesome out right now on your
YouTube excellent now put a linked it
out on the cam Tonka in the future it's
so weird yeah I'll put a link to that on
our website okay Marie Blair you know
comedy Facebook page I've combined
everything to one Facebook page around
that nobody goes to all right well first
of all it's always good seeing you guys
see you guys I'm a huge fan of both you
and I'm glad we're friends it's cool to
have such talented friends in case
you're worried your house is fine and
went to that place first I forgot you
even had the text change and I just went
straight to your substantively
I got out I'm like what am i doing I'm
sorry because I didn't realize you lived
in Venice oh yeah I'm an idiot cuz I've
only known you ten years and you've only
lived there twelve yeah yeah yeah I'm a
complete [ __ ] so I apologize across
town I come here a lot okay good uh
Henry Phillips Chris Fairbanks I check
out these guys when they come to your
town very funny thanks for listening I
actually have to be in Venice in the
next 20 minutes I'll take you yeah
all right see you guys
laughing in road it's a cuckold angry
doors representing guns and these
flights canceled flights running with
the London black this bounced checks
great Bachelorette bumps in the front
making out for your set and mid likes
doing Gollum or missing merger tried the
rental car has another megachurch to
juice keys vagina Pfister cellphone is
gone
one big Law & Order